yeah the book did make me feel really
good about being human on that level
where it made us seem like these swiss
army knives where we show up
and then we
niche switch uh we specialize we have
this like combination of generalists and
specialists who then manage to overrun
any habitat
it's good news with a giant asterisk on
it right the fact is
we are an incredibly special species and
we are adapted to something that no
other species i mean species deal with
it but we are adapted to change it's
what we do we bootstrap new software to
deal with new problems right we're very
good at it and that does offer nothing
but hope for the pickle we're in because
if any species was going to work you
know we created this problem but we're
also positioned really well to figure
out how to get out of it but
it comes with a lot of other stuff
selection has been pushing us in the
direction of just simply
getting our lineages genes into the
future at any cost and so the point is
human beings are capable of all kinds of
terrible stuff too
and
you know the deepest message in the book
may be
that it is time for us to take evolution
the mindless process out of the driver's
seat and to recognize our evolutionary
purpose isn't interesting or honorable
but we are perfectly capable of defining
a purpose that is worthy of us and
that's exactly what we should do at this
moment in history
[Music]
[Music]
it is my distinct pleasure and privilege
to welcome
to the forward podcast heather heing and
brett weinstein the co-authors of this
fabulous new book a hunter gatherer's
guide to the 21st century welcome to
both of you thanks andrew great to be
here great to see you again wonderful to
be here great to see you as well uh so
full disclosure i i
have admired both brett and heather for
quite some time and i also hung out with
brett's brother eric in the bay area
over the last couple of years so i it's
so that this uh this is going to be um
something of a fawning interview
[Laughter]
i guess you're all very used to that
uh so you're both evolutionary biology
phds
uh who managed to get a teaching
appointment in the same place which is
next to impossible from what i know
about academia so did you meet while you
were
both getting your degrees at the
university of michigan yeah that
so-called two-body problem and academia
is very very hard to break isn't it um
but you know we were we were lucky in
that regard we actually met each other
in high school we were friends in high
school no
i'm afraid so
what kind of nerdy high school was this
where was this at it was uh in santa
monica
california it was a
odd high school uh called crossroads
which actually uh the campus is an alley
with lots of repurposed buildings um
so it's a it's an eclectic school but
this was not like a high school romance
situation did you end up linking up
later or was it a high school romance
situation uh from i was i was in love
with heather from very early on but um
but no i
we did not get together until college
yeah we were friends for several years
before we before we got together and
and have been ever since
and so you went to college together and
it sounds like brett was crushing on you
a bit heather uh and then you started
dating and then you made a decision to
go get the your phds join me
we didn't go to college together we uh
we
left high school as friends and
uh
at some point i i went to different
coasts we went to different coasts and
uh
you know
i already knew how i felt about heather
but at some point i got a marvelous
letter and um we can allied the part
about how i botched the response to the
letter but nonetheless we did end up
dropping out of school together spending
some time and then going back to school
together wow
they should make a movie out of this
romance this sounds incredibly
romantic and quite eventful especially
after reading your book because
uh it seems like it's easier to try and
figure out where you haven't been as
opposed to where you have been like
anytime there's like a story in the book
it's like i remember the time we were in
central america madagascar
you name it
uh the the book is amazing i was excited
to read it um because the thesis is
around how
we
are in modern circumstances that may or
may not always be in keeping with some
of our evolutionary tendencies or our
own well-being and you all dig into many
areas in detail how has the reception
been i i get the sense that people have
been very very
uh excited to talk to you both
there's been extraordinary reception in
some places and um almost complete
silence in in others some of you know
some of what i would have hoped for 20
years ago in terms of what reception to
what turns out to have been a new york
times best-selling book hasn't existed
at all you know we we haven't we haven't
seen any talk in the the mainstream
outlets but um you know we're here
talking to you
and we've talked to this is as
mainstream as it gets heather
i think we've reached far more audience
than we would have if we had been
accepted in the atlantic for instance um
but it doesn't it hasn't followed any of
the paths that one might have expected
it to 10 years ago but then isn't and
you know this is part of what you
yourself talk about in your newest book
um that that is part of what modernity
is showing us that nothing that used to
be the case um seems to be the case
anymore so uh first of all you may you
joke
you're not the mainstream but you
hopefully are the headwaters we are
hoping to see that a small trickle that
emerges from somewhere and becomes a a
giant unstoppable force is the hope um
but i would also say there's some
analogy between what happened to our
book and uh and what happened to you in
the presidential campaign um in fact i
it would be fair to say tell me more
where were you we were yet called by
another asian man's name
they did for a while put up pictures of
of random asians in our place
now the what happened to us was the
so-called mainstream which
you know as we know is not the real
mainstream right people have gotten so
used to uh
you know being lied to that when they
hear authentic stuff they gravitate to
it and so the real mainstream is just
sort of not officially acknowledged and
you know from our perspective this is
what happened to you in the presidential
campaign right you were uh the idea
of hey an honest guy who wants to figure
out what the best solutions are and
isn't wedded to an ideology and isn't
wedded to um you know some particular
constituency
that was very appealing to lots of us
and so
what needed to happen was you needed to
be undermined
and they undermined you in every way
from
cutting off your mic when you had things
to say to putting up pictures of random
asian men and all of these and so the
point was
you know you didn't reflect in the
mirror right and
as heather points out our book sold out
almost instantly in fact within three
days of launch it was no longer
available
um it was so popular
and yet
from the mainstream outlets
there was radio silence and so
the popularity of it was all driven by
interviews on podcasts and word of mouth
and yes it's effectively like the modern
word of mouth and that you know that's
what grassroots is you know maybe maybe
there's no comparable word for
grassroots over in share this book space
but you know grassroots political
campaign and grassroots share these
ideas please is actually they're
analogous and they're what we refer to
in the book as as campfire at some level
it's you know let's let's get together
let's exchange and expand on each
other's ideas and then and then disperse
and find other campfires and see the
ideas there yeah i love that metaphor
and there are so many ideas in your book
that would strike some as common sense
what i love is you both have such
unassailable academic credentials where
you literally have two phds in
evolutionary biology saying hey
here's something about humankind and
look it applies in other environments
and look we're even going to throw in
another species just
just to show that
you know that this is very much based in
fact
uh
so
what
handful of things do you think would
lead someone in the mainstream to want
to for example not talk about your
your book if you were to pick out a few
ideas where you were like oh i think
they had an issue with are talking about
uh perhaps sex and gender in that way or
if there was another that uh that
sticks out in your own minds
i don't think it works like that i don't
think it's that individuals arrive at
the idea that they don't want to talk
about the book i think there is a
general sense
that
there is a narrative you ran into it in
the presidential campaign that narrative
is feeble and it it is vulnerable to
critique and the problem for the
mainstream is that evolutionary biology
provides a toolkit that actually allows
you to proceed from first principles and
deduce what's taking place and to say
things about uh virtually any biological
phenomenon be it a you know a pandemic
or you know the
climate policy and its effect on
habitats any of these things it allows
you to know how to walk into that
question and begin to address it and so
if you're attending a feeble narrative
you don't want people with their own
toolkit to say hey actually what you
just said doesn't make any sense here's
the way you would actually approach that
if you wanted to figure out what the
best policy was so
you know the more i the more i hear us
talking
the more i think what you ran into and
what we ran into is the same thing which
is an instinctive sense that that thing
is not under control and therefore it
needs to just not even be acknowledged i
guess i'll add that there's also a
cartoon version of what an evolutionary
approach to understanding humans is
that
immediately calls to mind things like
eugenics and nazis right you know those
people were doing darwinism and
therefore anyone who's talking about uh
darwinism or evolutionary principles
must be up to no good must be crypto you
know racists or sexist or whatever it is
and that has become sort of mainstreamed
in academia especially in social
sciences wherein people who are
sophisticated enough to understand that
they have to acknowledge that evolution
happens of course in terms of evolution
of hearts and you know the structure of
the brain
the you know there's effectively a
belief that once we're talking about
human culture and consciousness
that's something else that is explained
by some other set of principles and of
course that itself is a religious
position which uh which such academics
don't tend to acknowledge but it then it
becomes easy to say oh don't talk about
for instance sex and gender
because we're doing that over here in
this other space you people please stick
to you know squid and baboons where you
know where you belong
the nazis thought they were doing
darwinism but they weren't doing it well
and in some sense if you look at our
book and you read it carefully what you
find out is that the the most major
error that they made was that human
specialness isn't housed in the genome
right the genome is a platform on which
human specialness is built it is built
above it is literally epigenetic right
and so
the idea of a creature that is so
heavily software based that the normal
way that selection proceeds in other
creatures doesn't apply usefully if
we're to figure out
you know why why people succeed
so in essence
this was a very poor quality analysis on
their part and if you want to understand
what a good quality analysis is and the
good news from that good quality
analysis is human specialness is totally
democratizable and in fact that's what
we do automatically right we integrate
our cultures we borrow things from each
other and what we come up with is a
software program that is better than we
could come up with independently yeah
let's figure out the best ideas and
cultural norms across all societies and
make them available to all
[Music]
this episode of the forward podcast is
brought to you by better help is there
anything preventing you from achieving
your goals or interfering with your
happiness
betterhelp.com
yang is a fantastic way
to get your head on straight in my
opinion uh betterhelp can assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist so
connect in a safe and private
environment online it's so convenient
i've been using it probably for the past
eight months you can start communicating
under 48 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not particularly self-help it's
just professional counseling done
securely online you can communicate with
your counselor anytime whether that's
text or email or video
phone it's pretty awesome convenient and
it's available worldwide so whether
you're looking to help you with
depression or stress or anxiety or
relationships or sleeping or family
conflicts for me it's about
just letting off some steam and talking
about the real things that happened in
life and now let's all be real since
covid we've all been going through it so
i want you guys to check out betterhelp
and start living a happier life today so
as a listener to forward podcast you'll
get 10 off your first month by visiting
our sponsor at betterhelp.com yang so
join over one million people who have
taken charge of our mental health again
that's better help help dot com slash
yang
[Music]
yeah the book did make me feel really
good about being human on that level
where it made us seem like these swiss
army knives where we show up
and then we
niche switch uh we specialize we have
this like combination of generalists and
specialists who then manage to overrun
any habitat
it's good news with a giant asterisk on
it right the fact is
we are an incredibly special species and
we are adapted to something that no
other species i mean species deal with
it but we are adapted to change it's
what we do we bootstrap new software to
deal with new problems right we're very
good at it and that does offer nothing
but hope for the pickle we're in because
if any species was going to work you
know we created this problem but we're
also positioned really well to figure
out how to get out of it but
it comes with a lot of other stuff
selection has been pushing us in the
direction of just simply
getting our lineages genes into the
future at any cost and so the point is
human beings are capable of all kinds of
terrible stuff too
and
you know the deepest message in the book
may be
that it is time for us to take evolution
the mindless process out of the driver's
seat and to recognize our evolutionary
purpose isn't interesting or honorable
but we are perfectly capable of defining
a purpose that is worthy of us and
that's exactly what we should do at this
moment in history yeah that was the
conclusion of the book which was really
profound in talking about the fourth
frontier which is something that a lot
of people i think would agree with that
uh where
collision course with disaster species
wide
that this growth imperative
will
eventually make no sense uh it did put
me in mind of
jared diamond's book collapse from a
while ago which i'm sure you both
uh read read when it came out
it's consistent with what a lot of
people think in terms of the
sustainability of the environment where
if you have companies that have a growth
imperative then eventually in societies
you point out that our population is now
at seven billion which by the way when
we were all growing up what was the
world's population well it depends how
early you go but um i recall i recall it
crossing into
above seven in our adult lifespans well
because i i ask because i remember as a
kid when i learned how many people were
on earth i think it was either two or
three billion and so as a person that
number stuck in my head and then when
someone told me was seven billion later
i was like when it becomes seven billion
so i i want someone to take a look at
like what you know whether or not i'm
misremembering guys
i don't think you are i i remember
thinking about this about my
grandfather's lifespan my grandfather
was born in 1913
um and the world population doubled
twice while he was on earth which is a
staggering fact yeah and you know we
point out in the book that our desire
for growth is not unusual and you know
that's just like the goal being to
reproduce yourself into the future as
far as possible is not unusual it's also
not honorable so you know how do we
harness that desire you understand the
desire both for a personal sense of
growth and sort of a societal sense of
growth and abundance and there's always
more around the next corner and turn it
into something that is has the sense of
growth without actually requiring the
use of more resources because we can't
keep doing that yeah so we're going to
come back to what we're going to do
species-wide but i want to explore some
of the key ideas in the book and there's
so many
um you talk about medicine food sleep
parenthood
relationships so you could do a podcast
about really any one of these um but i
was trying to distill some of the key
points
uh and one of the things that stuck with
me is a story about
brett breaking his wrist and then having
uh
what sounds like a nightmarish couple
days like where it's like excruciating
pain and
you
end up taking another trip with it and
uh talk about how after a lot of
hardship
um eventually it healed and healed well
but that 95 of people would have
immobilized it cast it
maybe taken some pharmaceutical
painkillers
had done a bunch of other things
that
address one aspect of the injury either
the bone or the pain
but don't necessarily address the entire
thing
in terms of soft tissue recovery or
usability or any of those things and i
thought that that story
one
um
you know it sticks with you because you
know no one wants to be going for days
with a broken wrist without drugs in my
opinion
i mean
like i'd like to think that i'd do the
same thing you did but who the heck
knows um but but there was something um
where that principle applied many times
throughout the book where that you're
trying to hone in on one particular bad
thing you're getting rid of
um and then in the process of getting
rid of that bad thing
uh you end up having unintended uh
effects elsewhere yeah now that's
exactly right and with regard to that
particular story there's at least two
there's at least two things at play
we've got the fact that human bodies and
brains are actually anti-fragile right
we actually become stronger with use
with with insult even you know to a
point there you know there are certainly
insults and injuries beyond which we
cannot recover beyond which we cannot
repair um but the response to immobilize
all kinds of injuries which actually
would withstand would not only withstand
but actually repair more quickly if they
were able to continue to be used uh is
an aspect of modern medicine that you
know we argue is is an error beca
because it's employed as a hard and fast
rule you know when you break something
you immobilize it as opposed to what
kind of break is it does this one
warrant that kind of a mobilization if
so for how long etc
and then there's also just the tendency
to reduce
our experiences to single parts of
single parts of what they are i'm
feeling pain pain doesn't feel good
therefore i must get rid of it instead
of recognizing that pain is an adaptive
response
which we should consider you know what
is it that the pain is telling me what
might it be that i am doing that i can
reduce such that the pain goes away so
that i can use the pain as an indicator
of whether or not my behavior is helping
me or harming me as opposed to get rid
of the pain so that i can continue on
with frankly whatever i might be doing
that's causing me to be in pain so i
would uh i would just add
the
incident i broke my wrist i fell off a
hoverboard that um our younger so those
things are death traps by the way not
kidding those things are not i i i'm a
big fan of the electric unicycle but i i
would agree with you the hoverboard is a
death trap uh both in terms of its
battery and also its control mechanism
but anyway i fell off one as i was
getting on it for the first time and i
felt my wrist crack i knew what had
happened
and
the thing is i had harbored the
following belief for
i don't know since i first learned about
uh biology in high school
which is we are a kind of creature that
has limbs that can repair from a break
because many of our ancestors had breaks
recovered had offspring after that right
not every creature is like that a horse
is famously difficult to repair a broken
limb because a horse's ancestors if they
broke a limb very quickly got eaten by
predators and so there's no selective
force to build the repair machinery so
my feeling was okay i'm a creature that
knows how to repair its own limbs why is
the instinct to go to a doctor who then
immobilizes and does something that
is a novel intervention surely nature
has a program for what to do now one
caveat
i made very sure
that what i had was a fracture in which
nothing was misaligned there was no
indication that i had broken all the way
through right it was a crack
and i learned my lesson right i started
immediately
utilizing it just a little right that
was the thing that got me in so much
pain that first night
uh was that i used it too much i was not
super cautious with it right away but it
wasn't even weeks before i was way
better off right it was a few days
before i had some use of my limb and
then it quickly got better and you know
it very much reflected my hypothesis
that there's a built-in program and it
probably beats the heck out of a cast if
your break is sufficiently minor
and we do we do also as you know tell
the story in the book of our oldest son
breaking his arm when he was very young
and it was such a remarkable break um
that he needed surgical intervention and
you know without without modern surgical
capacity he would be deformed now
his arm would have stopped growing uh
and you know he would have you know he
would be very asymmetric and have much
lower functionality absent that capacity
so this again you know there are no set
and forget rubrics here and that you
know that also is one of the messages of
evolutionary thinking is that it
actually is clarifying and simplifying
but you do have to carry around with you
an expectation that whatever happens
okay i'm gonna have to think this
through just a little bit from first
principles to see what i should do next
as opposed to it's a break cast it you
know that's too simple a rubric yeah and
in fact uh in our older son zach's case
when he broke his arm it also points to
the central theme in our book which is
about novelty and what it can do to you
in fact our point is that we are in a
stage of hyper novelty right novelty
humans deal with well hyper novelty no
creature deals with and our older son
when he broke his arm in the spectacular
way it was a combination of a couple of
mundane novel factors a small set of
stairs and a hippity hop neither of
which have any analogy in the ancestral
environment and the combination of them
resulted in a child doing something that
would have been a rarity for an ancestor
right the forces were just too great and
the break was beyond what uh normal
repair would handle
now i'm going to give you some insight
into
my marriage for a moment
so
i grew up the son of immigrants
and my father was the type of person who
wouldn't see
doctors or medical professionals very
much
and i
am the sort of person who tends to
just
uh wait for myself to get better
uh you know i don't really uh
take drugs or
um
medicine i i don't even have right now
this is gonna sound terrible but like i
i don't even know who my primary care
physician is
like i would need to take a
go get one uh my wife on the other hand
um likes to treat so
um if i'm under the weather she'll just
like throw a bunch of
um things in front of me pills
digestibles whatever they are
uh and
sometimes i just take them because you
know like i i don't
um
care enough to uh to have a
like any conflict over it
just like
you know i mean i assume you know like
she's done some research and homework
there's some middle ground i'd imagine
uh where
one aspect of our different approach to
parenting was when our son was diagnosed
as autistic
our older son
uh where she would say hey i think we
should have um you know him like
evaluated or whatnot and i was always
like yeah he's fine he's fine yeah you
know like i i kind of had that attitude
and then when she did get him diagnosed
i was like oh yeah you were right
i don't know if this is a customary
dynamic between
parents so i'm sharing this in in part
because i imagine there are people
listening to this who might resemble one
or the other where they might be
someone who just ignores things i tend
to follow that camp honestly um or they
fall into a camp where they try and get
a remedy for everything
you're suggesting that there's probably
a better process
than either of those that's a that's an
amazing characterization that you just
provided and i suspect that that dynamic
is somewhat common in relationships
honestly and that um it probably to the
degree that it exists often falls along
those gender lines um that that men are
more likely to assume that uh they can
take care of it themselves with whatever
they've got on board already and women
are more likely to look to
the community the outside authorities
right to find the wisdom and bring that
in
both of which approaches are valid and
valuable although the second one is more
easily gamed in a global culture in
which the authorities aren't your
friends and the wise women with whom you
share in your coffee but actually um you
know anonymous often corporate entities
so i guess i would say that the third
way if you will
which
is is i think what we are suggesting in
the book is to consider what this thing
is that you have experienced
and you know how how out of step with
the millions tens of million depending
on how far back you want to go you know
billions of years of evolution that has
that has led to this point um
is your current experience and what are
the chances that it was hyper novelty
that got you into this and therefore a
relatively hyper novel solution that you
will need to get you out of it
or
can the tools that you already have on
board or a change in behavior for
instance uh affect you well enough to
get you out of the current mess that
you're in whatever it is um i would
uh
point out though
heather hints at this when she talks
about the difference between our
environment and the ancestral
environment in the ancestral environment
you would be wise to
take advantage of the advice offered
especially by people in your lineage who
had specialized in figuring out what to
do
it is possible
that some of what they would offer you
would be of little
medical
value right
but it is unlikely that long-standing
medical traditions even extremely
primitive ones would be harmful to you
right in other words
there is a selective process that
results in the accumulation of wisdom
about what to do about this and that
sort of thing and in fact pharmaceutical
companies have spotted this and they
have
uh done a bunch of globetrotting
looking for compounds in the forests of
the world that are being successfully
used
that they can borrow and shout eureka
over
we don't live in a world where
your instinct about how safe things are
is any good and it is nowhere worse than
when it comes to modern medicine
yatrogenic harm is incredibly common
things that we thought were safe like uh
like benadryl
tylenol it turns out there's a long
history of knowing it's not safe that
the public is largely unaware of but you
know benadryl
uh seldane um
erythromycin all of these things every
nsaid
turns out to have significant harms in
some of these cases your doctor probably
isn't even aware if you ask your doctor
about
heart damage from erythromycin they're
probably unaware that it does it
right nobody warns you about this with
advil and so
the problem andrew is that there is no
wise place to stand that allows you to
mitigate harm here we are constantly in
in
a choice between failure modes do i go
to the doctor and have my doctor tell me
what they always tell me oh here take
this pill is it safe oh it's very safe
really i know you don't know that
because i know how many drugs have
turned out not to be safe after decades
right one of the things i campaigned on
was alternative medicines because i just
instinctively admired and respected them
and one other thing that happens in my
household is that if my elderly chinese
mom is around she'll just throw some
herbal remedy in front of me and then i
will take it without
thinking twice about it
because i just think to myself
well i i'm very confident this isn't
going to harm me like it's probably
going to help me so let me just do that
like that that is something that i i've
just internalized naturally and that's i
mean that is we would argue effectively
an evolutionary perspective that you've
onboarded without necessarily knowing
that that is what it was your elderly
chinese mother
is bringing with her the wisdom of
generations of of millennia right in
this case and because of that you can be
very confident that it's not going to
hurt you it's possible that it won't
help
but it's unlikely to do harm it seems
you know there is there are stories
about whatever it is having helped in
the past and maybe some of those stories
are actually about um you know being you
know the preparation and the presence to
the loved one who is caring for you and
that you need you know your body needs
to know that it's protected for some
number of hours when it doesn't have to
be worried at all about you know risks
from outside you know maybe it's not
actually about the the botanicals or the
or the fungal medicine itself or maybe
it is i'm sure maybe there are cases in
both in both of those camps oh yeah i
i've been taking those herbal remedies
since i was a kid and
they certainly don't hurt
and a lot of the times it seems like
they helped
you know what makes them work even
better
if you chase them with chicken soup i
agree you just and that happens that
happened a lot i'd have the remedy and
that's a chicken soup it definitely it's
a it's a kind of a bringing together of
two medical traditions um and it uh it
has a synergistic effect uh so there's
another
idea in the book that you used in
different contexts that i loved is
chesterton's gate where someone shows up
and it's like hey there's this gate we
don't know what it's doing here let's
get rid of it and someone and then
someone says well we can't get rid of it
until you find out what it's doing here
you'll know when you know why they
installed it whether or not it's time to
take it out yeah you don't wait to see
what goes wrong after getting rid of
something to decide ah maybe we
shouldn't have taken that thing out at
all yeah that's all right we talk about
then we apply that to like chesterton's
organs chesterton's breast milk
chesterton's religions even right you
know look at all of the things that
humans have been living with
chesterton's ancestral medicines right
you know we don't simply throw these out
because there's some new thing on the
block new kid on the block and actually
i know you're going to say something
here but i'm thinking about this is in
the western tradition rather than the
chinese medicine tradition but early in
the 20th century there was a movement
among doctors to treat things like
tuberculosis with what was being called
heliotherapy which just means get out in
the sun right like get out in the sun
and get you good old helio therapy
literally i'm on board right and um and
also open air therapy which you know
these do not sound high-tech because
they're not but you throw up in the
windows towards you actually roll
patients out if they were not ambulatory
out into the sun where the air was
blowing and the sun was shining and we
still don't know all of the mechanisms
by which this works but it does work
into this environment came
one of the most amazing successes of
western medicine which is antibiotics
widespread antibiotics and instead of
using antibiotics on top of these
existing low-tech incredibly effective
treatments of heliotherapy and open air
therapy
what happened was in an effort to
control things to make things
constrained to make things easy to track
we moved patients inside we made windows
unopenable we made rooms tiny all of
which is going to increase the risk of
at least respiratory
infections and we just started treating
with the new instead of adding it to the
old you know why would we ever do that
why would we get rid of the old when
it's working when something new shows up
we should be adding rather than
replacing they yeah
sorry yeah yeah yeah yeah
get that person some sunshine some
chicken soup and some chinese herbal
remedies at least you're not gonna hurt
them and it turns out all of these
things have uh have reasons behind them
sorry i didn't mean to interrupt you oh
no not at all
um you know another thing from the book
where you pointed out
exercise tends to reduce depression and
anxiety it's like maybe we should be
prescribing that i was like oh my gosh
they're right or you know going outside
on the regular tends to make you feel
better which i find um
i think everyone finds it that any kind
of exposure to
uh the sun and nature
uh will help your mental health at least
in some measure i think you need to be
careful here andrew it sounds to me like
you're lazy shaming
well maybe i'm indoor shaming are you
indoor shaming i mean you know you're
shutting shaming
i don't know what you're doing i'm
shocked i'm sure it's in my head
yeah i mean i think you know we i don't
think we write this into the book but um
even just shooting to get outside into
the sun
for a few minutes early in the day
when we also know that getting direct
exposure to sun early in the day helps
with believe it or not sleep patterns
right not only does it help with a
depression and anxiety obviously you
know and and reduces your risk of
infection from certain things but it
actually just getting that
shift light that you know the blue shift
light that is reflective of the morning
sun
into your brain earlier direct into your
eyes the earlier in the day possible the
more likely you are to be able to fall
asleep easily at night and sleep well
and you know this is something that
as far as i can tell almost no one if
anyone was talking about 30 40 years ago
but 30 40 years ago already people were
having a ton of sleep problems
and you know what you know what was
associated with that
um electric lights at night no no
thinking about what the spectrum was
that they were uh that they were on uh
the use of increasingly the use of
pharmaceuticals to help you get to sleep
and alarm clocks alarm clocks that you
know blast you awake at a certain time
every morning regardless of where you
are in your sleep cycle none of this is
conducive to actually getting into a
rhythm with your own sleep cycle and in
fact um
i don't wanna i don't know enough about
the history to say but there is
something interesting about the fact
that what we've done
is used
coffee
as a substitute for the built-in system
we have for regularizing your pattern of
mental activity and inactivity
and you know coffee is something you can
sell right it's hard it's hard to make
money on sunlight and
um
i mean if you could it'd be a great
business
the sun tax well all right can you
everybody start
the football and see if we can find a
business model in here but yeah i don't
know what it starts out with the sun
shade we do the mr burns and we block
the sun and then we're like if you want
any sunlight got to pay the tax wait a
minute genius is that what this lockdown
stuff is are they going to sell us
sunlight
andrew i think you may have figured it
out mr burns might have gotten in there
yeah this is the the simpsons movie from
a while back
[Music]
have you thought about certain friends
and family members and what you're going
to get them for the holidays this year
well we have a gift idea for you and
that's hello tushy bidets because they
are eco-friendly they're a little techy
and they're actually affordable and
super unique it ticks all the boxes so
you can get tushy bidets as a great gift
for your eco-conscious cousin your neat
freak sister your whoever you want in
your family that might find this awesome
funny or eco-friendly it cuts your
toilet paper use down by eighty percent
and they're pretty awesome so look they
wash your bum with fresh water um and a
better way to clean than toilet paper
it's simple spray and pat dry it
attaches your existing toilet so no
plumber electrician needed super easy
you can get it done in like less than
eight minutes pretty awesome and it cuts
down your toilet paper use and budget by
eighty percent so saving money and
saving preventative waste preventing
yourself from excess waste so joins
millions of hello tushy happy customers
right now who take care of their you
this is a quote they take care of their
yule logs the dignified way that's
ridiculous but still hilarious so here's
the deal give the gift of a clean bum to
yourself or your loved ones this holiday
season and get 10 off plus free shipping
right now at hellotushy.comyang
that's hello tushy dot com slash yang
for 10 off and free shipping do it right
now
[Music]
uh you know what one thing this
conversation has reminded me of and this
i think you'll agree with this uh i was
running for mayor of new york city and i
was brought into yeshiva schools and
catholic schools and i saw these kids
who were learning in these environments
and then uh
i was
questioned about religious schooling and
i was very supportive of religious
schooling because i said look i like
they're serving these kids and if there
are individual issues like it should be
taken very much in the context of people
who are
educating their kids and like working
hard in a particular way that
you know is working with their community
and i got freaking lambasted for this in
a way
in
like
really i found it kind of surprising i
think that one of the things i'm sort of
suggesting is that i'm not sure what it
is but i think i naturally tend towards
um like a degree of
um
deference to
uh
wisdom that's been built up over a long
period of time uh and a degree of
skepticism towards what you'd consider
like a modern
rubric
where someone's like oh this is the way
you do it this is the way you do and if
you don't do this then you're like
screwing it up and it's like well
like
how long have you been at this and you
know they've been at this for a very
long time and like are there actual like
all you know like
is it such that applying these modern
standards is like working 99.9 percent
of the time whatever like all this
because like they're you know they're
anyway so this is what it reminded me of
because that like like i
um was shocked at the
um level of energy um around critiques
of
like uh different approaches um at least
to you know people are very passionate
about on the schooling side um there's a
there's a very very narrow focus i think
among the
you know the so-called elites the
educated coastal class of which we are
all members um on
religion we're past that right like many
people imagine that that is a sign of
sophistication to recognize that they
are beyond that and finding value in
traditions regardless of how you feel
about the sort of the central metaphor
of of a god um is somehow suspect and
you know you've seen this as you just
described and we've certainly seen this
as evolutionary biologists who don't
have faith ourselves but are uh you know
have found so much value not only in
these traditions but also in so many
people who do have faith that is not
antithetical to an evolutionary
understanding of the world and
frankly i think the
the the simple rubric that many of the
you know the liberal elites have with
regard to if religion then bad is
obscuring far more untruths in many of
the modern ideology
that they are somehow blinded to
yeah i would i would say the problem is
we're not comparing it to the proper
thing
religious schooling
is often done well
it is very easy to do badly right and it
has been used i think what you what you
got as pushback is
uh to the extent that it's honorable
pushback it is trauma from having seen
religion as an excuse to misinform
children about things that are really
the basis of our collective
understanding of the universe and
therefore the basis of
sound policy how are we to govern
ourselves it's one thing if you know a
god gave us a disposable planet and said
use it up because it's you know it's not
the ultimate point of this it's another
thing if we recognize actually we're the
stewards of the most interesting rock in
the known universe
and we are not allowed
to destroy it right we owe it to future
generations to leave it here so you can
see
religious schooling can be an opt-out
for things that are essential
that is often not what it is and it does
have this break
and the comparison
to me
the schooling that is non-religious
these days
shockingly almost across the board looks
effectively like a cult that is to say
it's a religion without having passed
the test of time
and
that is very frightening so many of the
things that are being dispensed in these
modern
secular schools including public schools
does not pass a scientific test either
and so if you compare those two things
to each other which error would i prefer
you know a kind of
uh you know
[Music]
metaphorical grounding that causes the
teaching not to be as modern as it might
be or a
grab bag of
assertions many of them
uh
cynical
designed to you know advance an ideology
i prefer the former
now the problem and what we argue in the
book is that we are stuck in this pickle
not just with schooling but with
everything there is in general nowhere
to go back to there is no diet there is
no way of educating there's no no i i
feel for you because you you were such
it seemed from reading your book
um you seemed like you were such uh
hands-on diligent parents
like when you say there's like no place
to go back to because as a parent you do
feel sort of stuck you're like okay you
know like which boat am i going to go
with
yeah very much so if i can just add in
before before we pivot in the way i
think you're you're going i want to say
i think there's a category error in
people's heads that explains partially
you know their sponsor excuse me the
response that you got andrew to um being
um accepting and embracing of religious
schools and the response that we've
gotten to which is that
religious school isn't a thing
you know yeshivas and jesuit academies
are not the same as jesus camp and
that's not to say that there aren't even
some you know evangelical um experiences
that may be worthwhile but you know that
that is the thing that most of us have
in our heads i think um at least among
the sort of the
you know the the liberal intellectual
class when we hear religious school but
you know oh that's you know those are
the people who take their kids out of
school so they never hear any talk of
evolution
and that you know that does seem like
yeah that's not that they are i guess
maybe i'm in circles where that's not
what i think of either
[Laughter]
but you know yeshiva's jesuit schools
episcopal schools you know there are a
lot of of ways to teach with a founding
in religion that's extraordinary the
problem i mean it is the the central the
central theme of the book is that we are
in effect across the board whether it's
gender or schooling or the way we govern
ourselves or any of these things
forced to architect something new and in
general it is not something that if you
simply know you can describe it right
you can't blueprint these things you
have to navigate to them you have to
prototype and go in the right direction
which means you have to agree what the
purpose of the exercise is so you know
whether your prototype was better or
worse than the last one and
this is a tough message because
most people
are what we would call verificationists
maybe we're all born verifications where
we look for evidence that supports our
perspective yeah the scientific
worldview requires you to do the
opposite you have to look at the things
that suggest you don't have it right and
so if you go through our book and you're
a consumer
you'll find it
right it's it is hard it's it's
unnatural and it's it's pain irritating
too yeah because you're constantly
having to reassess and change your mind
but it makes your model get better over
time it is the key to making your model
antifragile and so if you do this if you
if you're a verificationist and you go
through our book
if you're a conservative you'll say oh
they're conservatives right if you're
if you're
a liberal and you go through it you'll
think actually these people are radicals
right they're they're talking about a
total revamp right this is you end up
with a very very radical seeming
conclusion which we'll return to right
and the point is they're both there
right we're arguing for something
extremely radical and we're arguing that
we have to listen to the conservatives
as we prototype this thing because if
not the liberal failure mode is gonna is
gonna kick in like we've never seen
before and we're gonna have nothing but
you know unintended consequences from c
to shining c
so that's the message we have to
navigate anew which requires us to
understand what conservatives have right
and what they don't you should start a
political movement my friends
well one idea i also wanted to affirm
from the book that i loved so much which
was that like a myth can be false but
useful
uh i thought that was so powerful and
you use an example where all farmers are
told to plant their crops during the
fall moon because it's good for their
crops which doesn't make any sense
but because you know changes all the
time but it turns out them all
planting their crops to the full moon
makes them collectively more successful
because
uh predators aren't able to come eat the
crops of the you know because everyone's
planting at the same time so like the
damage will be less
uh and so if you were a modern you
showed up and you'd be like this is the
dumbest
suggestion in the world if you didn't
understand that there was an underlying
purpose yeah so i mean the phrase we use
is literally false metaphorically true
and we come in with our modern visions
and we listen to the words that people
say and we think that the words the
people say the cover story basically is
the whole thing and of course it's not
and so just exactly as you just said the
moon is effectively a giant sky calendar
that everyone can see
that is the same for everyone and so
you know fine put aside if you will
uh that the moon itself or the gods that
drive it uh care about when it is that
you the individual farmers are planting
and recognize that having this belief in
everyone's heads across a region allows
for synchronization of both planting and
harvesting and that reduces crop loss
because it synchronizes not just the
farmers and therefore their crops but
also the crop predators yeah in fact
it's a very beautiful story because
religious people who i in general get
along with very easily hate it when i
say this but
um
the moon and actually our entire solar
system
cannot have been the creation of a
loving god or gods because nothing's an
integer and so it befuddles every
attempt to to figure out how many days
there are in a year hey not even an
integer you know no wonder culture after
culture has thought they had the number
and then they've watched their calendar
march so that you know the planting was
off over time right
maybe the creation of a trickster god
what that's that's plausible that it's a
trickster god could do this right just
to mess you up but the basic point is
even in such a circumstance ancient
wisdom is actually
the result of a process that discovers
an elegant solution even when you can't
write it out right the discovery of how
long the year is is a very new discovery
the fact that the moon phase doesn't you
know isn't regular with respect to the
seasons because we don't have an integer
there either still the point is all you
need to do is get everybody to agree on
what day to do it that's where the
benefit comes from that day can move
within a month but the point is
everybody can see the moon and we can
all agree when it's full that's good
enough
[Music]
why are you giving
big tech companies rights and access to
your data
with no consequence it's ridiculous
you've got
frankly
every time you go online there are
companies that are taking your location
browser history you name it and using
that to make money off of you and so to
prevent them from doing that andrew and
i both use expressvpn and it's awesome
you download the expressvpn app you can
get it on your phone get your tablet get
it on your laptop i have on my laptop
you press a button and you have your
very very own virtual private network
where big tech companies nobody can have
access to where you are what data are
you using and hide your ip address that
makes you actively more difficult to
trace and sell to advertiser what's more
expressvpn it crips 100 of your network
data to protect you from eavesdroppers
and cybercriminals and what i like most
is how freaking easy it is to you it's
one click it's so easy it was rated
number one by business insider and a
bunch of other places so let's stop
allowing big tech to revoke our rights
to free speech why not revoke their
right to your data instead secure your
internet with vpn that we trust for
online protection visit expressvpn.com
yang that's
s
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p
dot com slash yang to get three extra
months free with our exclusive link for
the forward podcast listeners go to
expressvpn.com
yang right now
[Music]
so when i talked about you both starting
a political movement uh brett it seemed
like you were about to say something
which excites me
um one one of the things that i am so
i've been going through a particular
progression or evolution myself
uh and i've become convinced of a couple
of things
there's this narrow band of media
organizations that are talking to
ourselves and each other while like the
rest of the country is looking around
uh just getting more and more arrested
and agitated and more mistrustful
and and the rest of it um and i
personally am not content with hanging
out on like the in in like the corporate
lair talking to like a shrinking group
[Laughter]
like i want to go
to where
uh the people actually are and where the
the the
um
the frankly the country is either going
to be
won or lost
uh and
my
campaign it sounds like your book and my
campaign are similar that i just went
around to the campfires uh
and uh no um i see the power of the
campfires um right now i'm interested in
trying to make them more powerful still
maybe even uh getting resources to them
um because they are reaching as many or
more people
um than
the media outlets that for whatever
reason people still see as authoritative
in these dimensions
so
so that this is some of the the stuff
that i've been weighing and figuring out
how we can make use of um because i can
sense that certain the the narrative you
speak of
is
uh
it's it's less and less trusted
um and it's less and less worthy of
being trusted frankly like i i i'm not
sure when that worm turned but it
certainly you know like it it did at
some point um so so what are your
thoughts on trying to build what in my
mind would be a very difficult to frame
political movement because you're trying
to get people on board with a vision
while saying look i'm not going to be uh
dictating like hey when you do x y and z
it's more like we need some principles
in mind and then head towards uh
destination um well first thing to say
is uh i think starting a political
movement is a terrible idea i think
starting a non-political movement is a
great idea it's essential and this is
the moment and uh you're a pioneer in
this landscape and and uh i and i know
we applaud what you're doing um if i can
be candid
i think you're headed for a brick wall
and you know in some sense this won't be
the first time you've run into one and i
do think maybe there's a you know the
anti-fragile story of andrew yang is
unfolding in front of us but
in order to do what you're doing
you're going to have to defeat the
paradox of the lesser evil right this is
going to be used to
thrash your movement to shreds
at the point that we have an election
because
um
fill in the blank is going to be an evil
that requires us to vote for whatever
garbage the dnc wants to feed us right i
mean that's just the structure of the
thing and if you don't have an answer
to why
we cannot listen to that that there may
be hazards associated with fill in the
blank
but those hazards are an argument for
doing this now because those hazards
only get worse over time so you'll
remember during the last election the
unity 2020 proposal was constructed
specifically to defeat that problem so
that you couldn't say hey we can't do
this now because you'll elect fill in
the blank
right in that case it was trump
um because it may be trump again but
continue
well let's put it this way if it's trump
again then this is the only question
because
uh so many people have this sort of uh
ptsd that causes them to vote for
whatever garbage the dnc feeds them
because the you know don't forget
right the greater evil wasn't always
trump right it was mitt romney
right it was it was george w bush right
and these are people that we became
nostalgic for
during the trump era so the point is
this is just a this is a structure a
game theoretic structure designed
exactly to prevent you from doing what
you're doing and you've got to beat it
structurally in order to succeed so
what i would say is look
um people describe the structure that
you proposed
2020. yeah the unity 2020 structure
which some of some of your audience will
remember was
that we
effectively nominate a team
somebody from the left somebody from the
right right these would be
courageous insightful patriots
right and in fact your name was uh our
first proposal from for somebody from
the left um
and the idea is that they would agree to
run as a team
right you don't have to alter the
constitution to do this
one of them would run at the top of the
ticket the person who runs to the top of
the ticket is chosen by a coin flip
they would govern by consensus and only
in the rare instances hopefully never
instances in which they couldn't reach
agreement on what the best policy was
would the person at the top of the
ticket make the call and then four years
in the roles would reverse and they
would run uh with the former president
running as vice president and the point
was this neutralizes the lesser evil
because it doesn't borrow everybody
knows that their interests are
represented in the room
and so it doesn't actually borrow from
one side and risk electing the other
and we saw in our internal polling data
that actually the people who volunteered
to work with us were very evenly divided
so this structure actually worked so
between partisan like uh divided between
sides of the aisle right absolutely yeah
so the point was it didn't actually
spoil the election we also built in a
fail-safe and we said look if this is
not uh if this thing doesn't catalyze to
the point that it's a plausible
contender we'll pull the plug on it
which we did right so we were good to
our word but anyway that's all beside
the point
you need some structure to beat the
lesser evil paradox or they're going to
use it to destroy you and
um
look
you're doing the work um
i
we would be happy to we are fellow
travelers clearly we want good
governance and we'd love to figure out
what good governance is and we're all
open to listening to what the evidence
suggests and all of that
i am concerned that we are watching
um
a very rapid progression to some new
landscape that none of us have been in
uh and that i i agree i think it's
actually the most likely scenario right
now and if you play out the next several
years
um republicans take the house next year
maybe the senate very hard to have a
democratic victory uh policy wise if
republicans have
either one house or both
you roll into 24 trump is the republican
nominee
democrats don't know what to do they run
joe biden again
and then you have
in all
probability a trump victory uh or if not
a trump victory a trump
uh close call that he will claim victory
and in either scenario you wind up with
chaos and violence on the streets
uh and possibly an autocrat
um and a population that at this point
has been so
disgusted and disenchanted that that
they it's kind of slump into the end of
democracy
i think this is a pretty realistic
scenario well slump into the end of
democracy is an unfortunately very apt
vision i think uh
what is it slouching towards bethlehem
yeah slump into the end of democracy so
um
i will point out that there was a
structural solution to this too
uh
as
as this was all unfolding uh
i advocated
for convict trump
pardon him
and pardon anybody who was non-violent
in either the insurrection at the
capitol or the blm riots and neutralize
this right provide us a structure in
which these things aren't the charged
elements that control our next electoral
cycle so that we can actually figure out
what to do and how to govern ourselves
and begin to talk about what it is that
drove people
now into the streets for the entire you
know summer of 2020 in portland right
and into the capital on january 6. you
know they're at base they were you know
a small number of violent bad actors but
there were a lot of people who were
actually
who were actually acting from passion
and disenfranchisement yeah misguided
people
[Music]
i think i think the overall arching
message is look
you've started something
we're enthusiastic
to see it uh we'd love to help you think
through how to avoid the pitfalls
we've also started something
maybe they're the same something i don't
know but
uh let's put it this way every smart
person we know
is looking for the way out of a
political death spiral that is
threatening every
ounce of what made the west special and
it isn't just the us right we may need
to lead the west out of this if we can
figure out which way is up again but
but nonetheless the west is in jeopardy
this can't be allowed to unfold because
in effect
it's the chesterton's fence problem
right people don't understand as much as
there's
terrible frustrating stuff in our system
in desperate need of fixing and it has
needed fixing for decades they don't see
the part that works beautifully because
it just works and to upend it
we are we are
toying
with being in a far worse far less fair
far less dynamic and productive
world just simply by throwing out the
stuff that we don't realize is actually
yes it the the the well-being of the
west is not fairly distributed that is
absolutely true but
the west is very productive right you
don't want to throw out the productivity
you want to figure out how to make the
system fair that's the point yeah and
it's not like the the inequities are
going to get better under an autocrat or
whatnot you know i mean like we know
they'll get worse right the west has
been has
been capable of producing
of being productive but in a real way
like in it you know generating the
creative and analytical and healing and
communicative whatever it is that
individuals have passions and skills for
the west's ways of approaching people
and opportunity has allowed more people
access to all of those things to be
their best selves and you know one of
the things that that have been saying
for decades and i you know we sort of
approach it in the book is
for all of those who would argue that
the west is the worst place on the
planet that you know that we are doing
things far worse than anywhere else
it's very hard to do right now because
of of covet and the public policies
surrounding it but go somewhere else
like travel somewhere that isn't a
disney fied version of your home and
actually be there and hang out in the
town square or in the bar or whatever
regardless my last podcast guest said
the same thing where she she was in the
south of india and was like i love this
country and anyone who doesn't think
it's great should also go take a bus in
the south of india and you know you've
been
on many of those buses
uh i i instinctively loved this country
in part because you know my family
immigrated here and um my brother and i
have had the kind of lives that um our
grandparents or our parents could only
have dreamed of
yeah i mean uh
my my lineage has gotten awfully used to
fleeing for our lives and the fact is
you know america
has been
a great place for
my persecuted
relatives right it's been a very fair
place has it been perfectly fair no
right and you know
we are liberals right
we are very interested in seeing the
degree to which the system is
systematically unfair of course we want
to see that fixed that's the whole point
of the project right um
but
to the to toy with with the inverse
right
with making it desperately unfair in
some direction that at the moment seems
reasonable to somebody
is just it is the height of insanity and
yeah one of the problems
really for all of us but for educators
especially is to figure out how
to not teach caricatures of the past
where we can all see with the hindsight
of
50 or 100 or a thousand years
how
what mistakes looked like and how they
sent populations into totalitarianism
and no one imagines that they would
recognize that that when it was
happening to them in the present it
wouldn't feel the way they've been
taught it looked
in retrospect so how how can we actively
reflect and encourage everyone to
actively reflect on what do those early
things look like and if we can't then we
we will as you say
slump into the end of democracy
that will happen well you point out this
hazard at the end of your book
as one of the dangers
when you advocate for trying to
open up the fourth frontier and get away
from the growth for growth's sake
mindset that will lead us to catastrophe
over time
i did want to end
asking about how we can get there i
agree with you wholeheartedly it was a
radical proposal
i really liked the way your book built
up to it where it
stood to reason by the end they're like
oh yeah that's right if if we do
our uh reductionist
uh growth approach it is going to end up
being calamitous
for everyone
uh
and so what do you imagine in
uh in addition to obviously i think
everyone should read this book a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the the 21st
century and think deeply about how we
can
uh shift gears
what is the best approach in your minds
to try to activate groups of people
around this
different
uh this different mindset
it is a socially
self-catalyzing phenomenon that is
already clearly underway
there are a huge number of us who are
opting out of whatever that engine is
that's feeding us a narrative right and
we've opted into other things that make
sense and it's very frustrating clearly
to those who are attending the narrative
that we won't be dissuaded by their
periodic attempts to demonize you or joe
rogan or whoever it might be
so in a sense people are looking for
reason and they are finding people who
at the very least are
not lying to them and trying to figure
out where we are in history what we are
to do about it and
i think we can just show up and the
biggest obstacle
is that there is a culture of fear
around acknowledging
your doubts
about where we are and about our
leadership and about what's really
driving all of this
but people have to be emboldened and i
think
there are some of us who have stepped
out in front of this thing
and we've said this is not adding up
here's how you know right check our work
and
and watch us correct our mistakes when
we make them right and for each of us
who has done that in some
large venue there are a lot of people
who have stepped up behind us and said
you know what that does make sense right
we have large followings of people who
are opting out with us and i think the
point is
either you have the particular defects
of character that cause you to step out
first and then
discover what it is on the other side
that doesn't want that to happen
or you don't but each you know
each tier makes it safe for the next one
to step up and say you know i don't i
don't believe this either
and
if we keep doing that the point is it
grows and you know is there a solid
30 percent that will absolutely um
double down you know until they've
exhausted every conceivable mechanism
for doing so yes but we don't need that
30
we know from the hidden tribes report
that there is this exhausted middle that
is huge and frankly we don't really care
about each other's ideology it's beside
the point we're so off track that the
things we differ over are irrelevant we
need to get back to the basic process of
going forward well as you go as you
named your party right exactly and you
know you were seeing this in effectively
the campfires that you were doing
uh and we were seeing this
for 15 years in the classrooms and field
trips and labs at evergreen you know we
had
we had a non-elite student body some of
our students were elite and some of them
were veterans and some of them are
grandmothers and some of them have been
home schooled or unschooled or
montessori schooled or you know any
number of kinds of remarkable
educational experiences and they came
into
our classrooms as a diverse lot of
people 25 or 50 at a time
and
we created community by establishing
that everyone here is allowed to speak
freely and explore ideas and is expected
to publicly correct their errors if they
discover they have made them and to
never conflate the thing that comes out
of your mouth with the fundamental thing
that you are as a human being we don't
say if i disagree with you i therefore
dislike you as a person that is that is
a conflation that that will make america
yeah it worked like you know we were we
were doing this at a very much smaller
scale successfully in these actually
diverse classrooms for 15 years and it
was amazing like that did bring people
together and it revealed
it revealed how little actual
disagreement people have when they're
allowed to speak to each other
yep
you should just do that for the entire
country
how does it scale right and i think this
is part of what you you're trying to do
like figure out how it scales right well
you know you say that andrew and um
in some sense that's accidentally what
we're doing and it's not even the
country right it's for anybody with
years to hear that's what our our dark
horse podcast
is about i will say
when you do that as
you're discovering there are you know
the funny thing about the third rail
metaphor is that it's not up to date
because there are many different third
rails with different amounts of
voltage that one has to be concerned
about
um
[Music]
and the point is
for those who can get past the narrative
about you know
what's wrong with the people they're
suddenly listening to for those who get
past that
um there's a lot to be done and what
we're doing on our podcast isn't so
different from what we did in the
classroom it's it's in one way different
because we don't know our audience in
the way that we knew every single one of
our students but in another way it's the
same thing and it's part of a network of
people who are doing variations on that
theme you're clearly in this network
with a particular bent and anyway i i
think it's almost the only hopeful thing
but it's so big you know this this
network of people who are opting out and
trying to forge the path forward that it
it really it really does give me and us
hope
yeah oh you all give me hope and i
learned so much in this book about being
a better human
husband partner parent may forward meet
the fourth frontier together
oh yeah we can put
your book
oh wow well thank you heather i really
appreciate it um so great to be able to
sit down with you all
everyone should buy their book it will
make you a healthier wiser
more in touch with your own humanity
person
and congratulations on a massive
achievement you know reading it was a
lot of fun i learned a lot about you and
your family
you know and some of the environments
you've been in but should be really
proud of it
thank you thank you really appreciate
that andrew and uh glad to find
ourselves uh on the same on the same
road i hope that this is the first of
many conversations both oh no doubt um
for sure we'll do it in person at some
point great yes looking forward
[Music]
you